Mình tạo thống bởi giám đốt tình bảo của giả Mỹ tưởng C. Gaward, công buồn một bảo gạo với trình gái trong đó
Cawbook các quan trức cấp cao thuộc chính quyền cử tổng thống b đá thảo tổng thống tổng thống tình bảo
liên qua đến cuộc bầu cử tổng thống thống năm 2019. Theo Bawg Gaward, mục tiêu của hành động này là làm xíy
vô trên tháng cục đồ nân Trump và tạo tình đe cho một trên dịch kéo dài nhằm cả chở nhận kỳ của ông.
Bảo cao cho rằng các cửa quân chức vôm cử giám đốt tình bảo của giả James Clapper,
gử dạm đốt C. E. A. John Brandon và Kiu dạm đốt F. B. E. James Cô Mi đã sử dụng thông tình bảo chưa được sát thực cũng như không hoàn toàn đảng tình cầy từ phía trong mình vương của anh
và giùi sau đó được giả kyl loạn không trí giá, bà tuy xí gà bát cho biết bà đã chuyển góc bằng chứng cho bộ tư pháp để xem xét khả năng truy tổ hình xử ở bà mà và các cử thực thật cấp
phía kêu tổ thông chưa được ra phản hồi trong khi đó các thành viên đảng dân chủ tại quy băng tình bảo hà viện đã chỉ trị bảo cao cho rằng để lần nỗ lực trứng chỉ nhằm đánh lạc vương rưu lật
trước đó vào những kỳ đồng tiền của mình ông đường năng trâm nhiều lần tuyên bố của nếu chá về cả năng truyền dịch của ông
có thông đồng với phía ngà là Trò Lưu B. Bảo cao của một công tổ viên đặc biệt công bố năm 2018,
các bạn hình cũng có bằng chứng cho thay trên dịch trình cửa của ông trâm hợp tác với mắt các bạn ngà cũng phụ nhận các cáu vô cán thịp bộ cửa Mỹ